what about your opinion of women when
you were a kid Changed by doing doing
this
job so what about my opinion about women
has Chang yeah because when you're a
young man you're like you know girls are
nice and they smell nice and you know
sugar and spice and all things nice and
then you start doing bachette parties
and you know all these sorts of gigs
like what opinions about women
changed well I uh hopefully this doesn't
get complex but if it does uh let me
know um
you know I've always been a very
self-aware kid man like I question
everything I've always been I'm always
the a little philosopher um asking
questions about anything and everything
when I was a kid growing up you know
born in
1990 watching the late night shows
comedy shows I always noticed the guy
was played as the the dad was the bath
the bathoom the idiot husband right and
I always I always question I remember I
was a teenager like why
is the father always the idiot like
isn't there like some kind of you know
Alpha like in a comedy show like a some
kind of alpha guy why are they
portraying the dad as a as a idiot and
then um my upbringing you
know I always heard the oh you know men
ain't [__] your so and so Dad ain't
[__] or and then you hear like other
single moms or blah blah blah like you
hear it like there's just a constantly
repetitive thing but I always noticed
too
with um you know just a common thing uh
socially too what I've noticed growing
up
and um as soon as I started diving in I
just I noticed
also you know women aren't as um sweet
and sweet and nice like everyone uh
portrays them to be because I once I
started working the field like yeah like
women as women are as horny and want all
these nasty things just like men like
what what are people talking about that
women aren't
um don't
want rough sex and or you know they
don't they don't crave these things of
course they are they're they're human
just like
us uh but I mean honestly it it has
changed
now and wanting to get married I'm going
to be completely honest like I I don't
want to um even the parties that I do or
even that the black girl that I met at
the show like there's a there's a small
amount of Hope but it's not like how it
used to be like Traditional Values um
and
with I think I'm going all over the
place but yeah I I I just I wouldn't get
married man um unless like I'm married
or you know unless I meet somebody and
the state is on the man's side with
50-50 but you know I've read your book
I've gone really deep into a lot of
different uh things when it comes
to uh what would happen if a man gets
divorced in a state that doesn't favor a
50-50 in the court system like that's
just not ideal so yeah that's how it's
changed I hope that answered it yeah I
know that that makes sense because I
guess you see them
would you call them at their worst or
behaving their
worst for the bat parties
yeah in some cases yeah sometimes they
you know they just want a a cute guy
with his butt cheeks out um in an apron
just serving them drinks and you know uh
they'll just flirt but they won't take
it to the to the distance of they want
to you know they'll they'll want to have
sex with me or uh any of the guys there
and sometimes some parties do take it
far I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out